[Music]
it's our girl
lily
mother
it's our girl let's sing baby
um
she's really good at impressions
she's really really good at praying you
think it's the real person i almost feel
like doing a chip jefferson right there
yeah more like lily dance
here we go
royce hates chip royce hates jim norton
and chip more than i think he hates jim
nor maybe more than i i do
it's just like you can't even jokingly
do a chip because royce would be like no
no
we'll just sandbag it ah
lily sing baby
oh sorry the title eminem raps about m
m's
oh
it's a good premise the candy that's a
pretty good premise dude
good it's good it's good um
get ready
i ain't 50 cent but i take you to the
candy shop don't want no gummies in my
tummy
pause pause she sounds just like him
nothing about this sounds like eminem
right yeah
he doesn't rap like that he does
like we were talking about this off the
air i'm not a big chris delia fan i just
don't find him funny but objectively his
eminem impression is one of the funniest
most accurate portrayals right ever i
think of course i'm wondering i can see
that i'm driving a porsche over the
floor
but he at least does the eminem cadence
and he does the eminem thing and divorce
at the same time
look what i'm planning she's doing the
same thing she did in that opening promo
like my name is lily and i'm not a white
man she's rapping like the 80s
yeah
oh she puts no effort into anything she
does really look at her show she's the
worst i ain't 50 but i take you to the
candy shop don't want no gummies in my
tummy so no f and lollipops cause eminem
give you eminem so your teeth start to
rot i give you calories through my
lyrics right through your airpods so
tell me what you want darker milk
chocolate press those peanuts in my
pocket
supposed to be funny though like this is
what i don't
it's just you're just rapping about
candy
this is offensively bad right this is
like 14 year olds that like this right
like who who else who else would like
this honestly okay but are there 14 year
olds up there up one in the morning
on week nights watching [ __ ] late
night television i guess not
[Music]
[Music]
also i don't like the fact that you're
dressing like a man it feels like you're
making a mockery of the trans community
because
you're also making a mockery of the late
night community and the comedy community
and the television community you're
making a mockery of everything as
impossible as it sounds you're bringing
indians down a peg or two yeah seriously
how did you manage to do that that was
already such a low bar i don't
[Laughter]
you still too know maybe kids will holla
more if the word newbie sounded nice you
ain't right you a clown prove it so you
know it's true it's right i'm sorry so
this joke is about the so even writing a
diss track about candy bars even the
premise of this is that she likes m ms
is this ca is it candy wrap yeah bro
they're in your name everyone laughs at
you twizzlers don't get it twisted you
bitter citric acid is one ingredient
listed listen if i wanted plastic two
bloody straws for fun i mean for
breakfast or for lunch you might be
crisscross but you ain't making anybody
jump she's writing a diss track
about twizzlers like she's dissing
snickers and twizzlers
you see what she's doing right there
that's what i do every time i watch one
of her videos this is what i don't get
right there's no honesty in that writing
room like let's say this we're gonna
we're i'm gonna be lily you're gonna be
the writer and you're gonna pitch me
this idea hey guys do we have any ideas
something new for a sketch we got to get
something out there all right so here's
what i'm thinking all right all right
sorry here's what i'm thinking so like
okay what we do is like you know how
like eminem the rapper
kind of like it sounds just like eminem
like the candy sure okay so like what if
we do like a wrap like how eminem likes
m m's but like he hates other candies
you're fired get out that was the worst
idea i've ever heard anybody else have
an idea anyone anyone else you see
everyone else just crumbling up their
papers would anyone like to join her
that's it i would be if if i were
in charge of the block of programming
that lily singh were in
i would be walking around those offices
like frank cross from scrooge
and now
i have to kill you
[Laughter]
sorry
two and a half bites even second cody
didn't want you in this sweet life left
and right
see because zach cody sweet life of zach
was a show
also it was spelled sweet like as in
sweet so you actually got that wrong
okay really you're right
you both dumb it takes two years i still
got more than you cause i'm melting your
mouth not in
anything like it wouldn't you have
somebody write a song in the tone of
eminem
this is all they know mike they don't
know anything else about this
quarterback
at least that was an accurate portrayal
that's why you're panicking
you're looking to stay on the mannequins
and i'm going
fan against trying to get up a plan
against let's see all of the planet
cassandra can fan fan panickings without
abandoning santa canana in the cabana
you're in a i'm in a cabana enchanted
i'm in a cabana chat in order to stand
up banner well you don't got the stamina
you're lanking the stamina this is so
accurate compared to here
she's pretty good man taking references
from other other m m songs does it make
it an m m rap by the way mouthful bites
are tasty there's chocolate on his face
already his heart is racing he's calm
but inside his pain for this you know
she's doing the to
lose yourself but the royalty freaky
because she doesn't want this uh to get
copyright claims because you know eminem
is going to be like i don't want
anything anything to do with this
loser-ass brand of yours yeah that sugar
is raging starts pacing this candy all
over the place i'm so so bad for your
teeth but still so good with the taste
buddy half of what that very leaves
is she a stand-up comic is she a late
night host
does she do skits
or is she like a weird owl music person
because i feel like you have like have a
specialty
is she is she everything in nothing is
she a youtuber is she a bisexual woman
of color empowered person like
what is she royce she is a a renaissance
woman
a jack of all trades
what she said telling you what she is
she is so good
our talent transcends genres
i don't know what's so hard to
understand about she's a hero rice
[Music]
you're aw
is what you are you're a canadian
well not
your canadian
is what you are and she's also trying to
look like eminem but she actually looks
like the weeknd
let's look like the no she looks like
the weeknd you know what she look that's
one but you know what she looks like to
me aziz and sorry trying to be incognito
at a supermarket
damn man if i keep wrecking that let me
[ __ ]
i just asked paper or plastic sir oh man
see you they recognize me again yeah i'm
aziz ansari no nobody i don't really
know who you disease does strike me as
the kind of guy that goes out and like
notices himself for people
like okay yeah look no autographs or
anything and everybody's like what i
don't even know who you are you also
have a better chance of getting me too
by lily singh than by [ __ ] aziz i'm
sorry
[Laughter]
yeah girl yeah i don't need to eat you
out of you having fun
[Music]
two and a half minute video of candies
if you don't like me you should have got
something else instead like machine gun
kelly if you want it in their head you
can put me in a visit a flurry my whole
life is a storm that's normal i'm a rap
god i'm partying sunday but no church
flurry isn't a candy bar
i guess cause candies go into mcflurries
but that's then you've already covered
it but based on the things that you've
already been talking about
yeah like if i diss reese's pieces and
then i dissed mcflurry it's in at this
like if i [ __ ] on reese's peanut butter
cups and then [ __ ] on blizzards it's
like all right but you already covered
that i don't know if you know this mike
but there's only so much candy wrap you
could do
like after a while you have to start
bringing mcflurries and other desserts
not enough
of the theater
the perfect gift from christmas why are
we gonna
i'm sorry
are we gonna keep allowing canada to
send us this trash
because at this point i'm more for
[ __ ] protecting that border why are
we allowing canada to send us this trash
here why are we allowing it we should be
allowed to send them 10 very violent
dangerous
child slash murderers for every one of
these
okay someone like her or a crowd or
gavin every time they send us one we
send them 10 of the most despicable
child
then who's going to make our movies here
you're right that would just be trading
good talent for bad talent
i was gonna make movies here i don't
know
this was a terrible trade i mean it's
the worst you got crowder and lily sing
and they got harvey weinstein and kevin
spacey [ __ ]
kevin spacey lives in quebec now
i will [ __ ] that french canadian twink
mouth if you don't respect someone says
i don't mean to play devil's advocate
but canada sent us ryan long i love ryan
long ryan long's hilarious
but
sacrifices must be made yeah i love ryan
long i think he's one of the funniest
guys out there i will personally put a
bullet in ryan long right now if it
means we get to send her and crowd her
back that's just no offense ryan i like
you ryan but i feel like he would
understand yeah i feel like he'd be like
yeah i get it i mean i don't want to die
but sure
it's for a good cause
as he's just flinching getting ready for
the bullet
it's been a good run boys
he does it he's sitting down and he's
just watching hours of their videos
going i'm ready
i'm ready i'm getting the gun out yeah
you're getting all ready to shoot it and
then he tearfully goes
boys boys boys
boys
he just
this blows the red green red green on
your wish list
[Music]
hey but you know what why don't we see
why don't we see what her fans have to
say because i i bet you they're going to
be like reasonable and they're going to
like her it's um
i get sick of twix lily sync 20 2k 20.
who else wants us to to be an eminem's
ad not the eminem's people uh only if
there was a rapper named skittles
mom so are his so are his teeth doctor
dentists ma'am this boy is storing five
m m's okay i can't get it is there
anything lily can't do
so much talent in one person how is that
possible